hey 42 here on the 11th of April 1880
legendary U.S army General William T
Sherman stood in front of 10 000
graduates from the Michigan Military
Academy and dotted three short words war
is Hell
rarely before all sins has such a
complex subject being summarized so
succinctly the death and destruction the
flying bullets and exploding shells the
screams of the dying and the Silence of
the Dead hell is the only way to
describe it
in his 14th century epic poem The Divine
Comedy Dante Alighieri imagined the
underworld as a vast pit made up of nine
concentric Rings the dpu traveled into
this spiral of damnation the worst
things would get if war is indeed hell
and we take Dante's Doom spiral as our
model of it then the Battle of ramri's
Island belongs in the Underworld ninth
and most nightmarish Circle
sometimes called the ramri massacre for
reasons that will soon become clear the
Battle of ramri Island was a relatively
small engagement that took place towards
the tail end of the Burma campaign in
the final year of World War II in total
under 1 000 soldiers lost their lives
Small Potatoes by the horrifying
standards of the second world war but it
wasn't the volume of death that made
this particular battle so terrifying
it was the cause because the soldiers on
ramri island weren't killed by bullets
bombs and bayonets they were slaughtered
in their hundreds by giant man-eating
reptiles
this is the horrifying story of the
ramri crocodile Massacre the single
deadliest animal attack on humans in
recorded history
but stick around to the end because this
one comes with a Twist
before the outbreak of the second world
war Burma now officially known as
Myanmar was part of the British Empire
but the British were driven out by the
Japanese in 1942 at the start of the
Burma campaign three years later the war
was almost over and with Japanese forces
suffering heavy losses across the entire
Pacific Theater the Allies began
wrestling back control of the former
British colony
the first step would be to retake the
capital Rangoon as part of operation
Dracula but to do that the Allies were
going to need somewhere to base their
Vital Air Support ramri Island was
chosen as the perfect spot just 200
miles from Rangoon it had plenty of open
lands suitable for airstrips that could
be supplied by the deep water ports on
the Island's Northern tip right from the
very start the Battle of ramri Island
was a one-sided Affair the Japanese
Defenders were outnumbered six to one
and with the Allies able to call on
devastating Naval and air support at
will they were outgunned by an even
wider margin
the initial assaults dubbed operation
Matador kicked off on the 14th of
January 1945 with an amphibious landing
on ramri's pristine Northern beaches
Royal Navy reconnaissance plant had
spotted Japanese soldiers installing
artillery in caves along the shore in
preparation for the imminent invasion
so the British Navy sensed the
dreadnought-class battleship HMS Queen
Elizabeth supported by dozens of smaller
ships and the variety of air supports to
rain down fiery death and prepare the
way for landing
by the time the sun had settled the
Allies were able to stroll onto the
island entirely unopposed it was almost
like a summer holiday except everything
was on fire
by the following day the port had been
captured and the Allies began to work
their way South resistance was
significantly Fierce or further Inland
where a thousand Japanese troops fought
like tigers over every inch of ground
given
both as the Allies solely spread out
across the island it became clear
resistance was futile ramri was lost
at this point the Japanese General
kinichi nagazara had a decision to make
most military leaders would simply have
waved the White Flag but by this point
in the war the Japanese had made it
abundantly clear they would rather die
than suffer the shame of surrender in
this case however there was a third
option Escape if nagazawa and his men
Were Somehow able to make it to the
mainland they'd be able to join up with
the bulk of the Japanese Army's
remaining forces there is just one small
problem with this plan between nagazara
and the safety of the Mainland was a
vast Mangrove swamp a near impenetrable
Maze of trees which was either covered
in thick oozing mud or waste high water
depending on the tide this hellish
Labyrinth was infested with tropical
disease carrying mosquitoes poisonous
scorpions and spiders and most ominously
of all massive salt water crocodiles
all in all it didn't sound great but on
the plus side The Mangrove swamp was so
thick that the Japanese troops would be
all but invisible both from the ground
and air and it was so dangerous that the
Allies surely wouldn't dare to follow
them inside in early February the
Japanese abandons their fortified
positions on the island and ventured
into the swamp
most would never make his house alive
saltwater crocodiles are Ambush Hunters
they wait motionless for hours on end
and despite their bulk they can make
themselves practically invisible in just
a few feet of water
if something tasty looking gets too
close they explode into action clamping
down on their prey with a biting force
of 3 700 pounds per square inch that's
about four times more powerful than a
lion
once they've latched on salt water
crocodiles execute their Mortal Kombat
finishing move the death roll tearing
whatever is in their mouth to bloody
shreds
the Japanese soldiers on ramri entered
the mangrove swamp in a pretty bad
condition they'd been fighting non-stop
for several weeks and many were ill or
injured in hindsight they never stood at
chalice against what was waiting for
them the crocodiles mostly hunt at night
and as the soldiers ventured Through the
Jungle they were picked off one by one
it's hard to imagine just how terrifying
that must have been one moment you're
carefully picking your way through the
swamp By Moonlight and the next
something huge shifts in the darkness
and you're being dragged beneath a
chilling Waves by a creature big enough
to quite literally swallow you whole
some of those who were there to witness
this horror first hand have written
accounts of what they saw amongst them
was accomplished naturalist Bruce Wright
a lieutenant commander in the Royal
Canadian Navy he recorded his
description of the crocodile massacre in
his 1962 book Wildlife sketches near and
far it made for an incredibly chilling
greed that night was the most horrible
at any member of the motor launch Cruise
ever experienced
the scattered rifle shots in the Pitch
Black Swamp punctured by the screams of
wounded men crushed at the jaws of huge
reptiles
and the Blurred worrying sound of
spinning Croc tiles made a cacophony of
hell that has rarely been duplicated on
Earth at dawn the vultures arrived to
clean up what the crocodiles had left
of about 1 000 Japanese soldiers that
entered the swamps of ramri only about
20 were found alive
rights account is an accurate summary of
how the story has been told ever since
you can find it in countless reference
books documentaries YouTube videos and
podcasts for several decades the Battle
of ramri Island was even featured in the
Guinness book of records as the animal
attack with the most human fatalities in
history
but in recent years both historians and
herpetologists that's people who
specialize in reptiles not STDs I've
started to question whether this
remarkably gruesome tale can really be
true after all it does sound more like
something you'd see in a movie theater
rather than the theater of war
so what really happened on memory Island
80 years ago
let's start by looking at the villains
of the piece the crocodiles
saltwater crocs are the largest reptiles
on Earth that's pretty common knowledge
but most people have no idea just how
absurdly enormous these beasts can get
if left to their own devices far from
Human interference they can reach a
staggering seven meters in length and
weighs on 2 000 kilograms
in other words this is an animal that's
significantly longer than a giraffe is
tall and about the weight of four large
grizzly bears combined
thanks to their incredible size combined
with their natural aggression and a
surprising level of intelligence these
literal cold-blooded killers are the
Undisputed apex predators of any
ecosystem they find themselves in they
are quite simply one of the most
dangerous animals on the planet
you may have seen footage of people
swimming with sharks but nobody gets
into the water with a fully grown
saltwater crocodile if they have any
plans of getting back out again despite
the fact most large saltwater crocodiles
live far from Human habitation they're
still responsible for multiple
fatalities every year
so yes given the opportunity the
crocodiles on ramri island would
absolutely have killed any soldiers who
got too close
but here's the thing according to the
most commonly told version of the story
around 900 men were killed by crocodiles
in just a few days
trouble is that kind of crocodilian
Carnage could only have been possible if
the swamp was teeming with thousands of
extremely large saltwater crocs and yet
there's neither the food nor the space
to support such a high density of mature
adults in the ramri mangrove swamp
put simply the legendary tale of the
ramri crocodile Massacre is an
ecological impossibility a military myth
born out of a decades-long game of
Chinese Whispers combined with a
straightforward misunderstanding many
people have written about the massacre
over the years but Bruce Wright's
account is the primary source that most
people have drawn on that makes sense
right wasn't just a soldier serving in
the area at the time he was a respected
naturalist who knew what he was talking
about when it came to crocodiles or at
least people thought
but in 2001 her pathologist and ramri
Massacre skeptic Stephen Platt notice
something interesting about Wright's
account almost every Wildlife anecdote
in the entire book in which it appears
is written from Wright's own perspective
but the chilling tale of the crocodile
Massacre is written in the third person
and it turns out there's a very good
reason for that right wasn't actually
there when the alleged Massacre took
place his version of events comes from
conversations he had with those who were
and it seems a few of the details may
have been embellished along the way
there's something else interesting about
Wright's account he never actually
explicitly stated that all the soldiers
were killed by crocodiles only that one
thousand soldiers entered the swamp and
just 20 came out alive
as we've already seen there were plenty
of other dangers waiting for the
Japanese amongst the mangroves including
tropical diseases and a variety of
poisonous creepy crawlies probably even
more deadly were the conditions
themselves the sucking mud that would
have sapped the already weak soldier's
strength the lack of food and the
brackish water that wasn't safe to drink
not to mention the Allied soldiers
patrolling the swamps scattered open
waterways in boats who would likely have
shot anyone they came across
[Music]
put all this together and it seems
ridiculous to assume that all 900
soldiers were murdered by Massive
misanthropic crocodiles more importantly
it turns out the numbers themselves were
rung in the first place we can debate
what may or may not have killed 900 men
in a swamp 80 years ago till the cows
come home but according to official
military records a solid 500 of them
didn't actually die at all they made his
house alive to join up with their other
comrades on the mainland total
casualties attributed to the entire
six-week battle are estimated to be only
500. it's extremely likely that
crocodiles were responsible for some of
those deaths but it's an absolute
certainty that the true number is orders
of magnitude smaller than most people
have been led to believe
these days the general consensus amongst
historians is that most of the 500 poor
souls who died lost their lives either
to drowning or The Guns of the allies
with crocodiles mostly just Scavenging
the corpses when they got the chance
truth is we'll never know the real
numbers like Bruce Wright who started
all this trouble in the first place we
weren't there most of those who were are
no longer with us and even if they were
exactly what happened on the cover of
those mangrove trees is inherently
unknowable those on the outside couldn't
see in and those who perished took their
secrets to their watery Graves
thanks for watching